what's going on guys this is Rob and
doomsday has become the king of Hell
he's literally taking it over and it's
amazing dude this story is so cool so
what this does is this opens up with
Martian Manhunter meeting with Supergirl
Kara zorrell and the reason for this is
because she's having nightmares of
Doomsday in Hell itself which for her
they seem very very visceral and very
very real where she wasn't 100 sure
whether it was happening or not once she
meets with Manhunter he literally tells
her I sent you a nightmare and the
reason why is because he basically says
last night I received a message a
psychic code that I did not understand
it was in Kryptonian before it faded I
had to send it somewhere to someone who
might translate it for me and Supergirl
picks up on the fact that it was sent to
her instead of Superman because of the
fact that doomsday killed Superman it's
one of the things that was important
about his character in the aftermath of
like the death of Superman's storyline
where in a lot of ways he kind of
struggled with like PTSD dying at the
hands of Doomsday and so on and so forth
although DC undid it in the most
ridiculous way ever but it makes sense
that it would happen right not only this
but the reason why Martian Manhunter
even had this kind of psychic code in
the first place is because during the
event of Lazarus planet where doomsday
was trying to bring himself back to life
Martian Manhunter was able to prevent
that from happening but his telepathy
kind of connected with doomsday and so
he's almost kind of always aware of what
doomsday is doing to a degree so
doomsday being in hell and taking it
over is literally an image that Martian
Manhunter got even if he didn't fully
understand it and so what ends up
happening is we get this kind of
explanation about the nature of hell but
even with them they're basically pulled
forward now one thing to know is that
this hell is not the true hell NDC
comics and the reason why I say that is
because in DC you do have
judeo-christianity God Lucifer
Morningstar so on and so forth so
Lucifer rules over the actual real true
hell that exists out there this is more
of just kind of a figment of humanity
imagination which is to say that the way
it's explained humans believe it's real
therefore it becomes real it's just kind
of the end comic explanation for why it
exists right that's really all it is but
the thing about this is that as Kara
zorrell comes to understand the message
that was sent to her by Martian
Manhunter the two of them are actually
yanked to this Dimension directly and as
they get through there what they start
to witness is really just like the
aftermath of Doomsday seizing control in
this area they don't fully understand
exactly what's going on and we're kind
of given a description of it right like
the fires of Hell burn hotter than any
on Earth they are not enough to Scourge
Souls the only part of the human anatomy
that cannot be destroyed by Earthly
Flames though they burn slower of course
to allow the agony to be extended right
that kind of a thing but the other part
of this is that within this realm itself
doomsday as a being that cannot be
killed we're given this amazing
monologue in terms of what he's doing
right we're told are being who cannot
die the same way twice who takes
whatever trauma has been bestowed upon
it absorbs it and becomes more powerful
from it it is almost as though hell was
purpose-built for such a being he has
been learning so much he's been finding
so many new ways to be destroyed
learning so many new ways to inflict
suffering and the Demonic and the damned
have begun to speak of him in hushed
Whispers they have begun to refer to him
by a new title hail King doomsday so
that's kind of the interesting thing
here the more people in this realm
believe in the realm the more the realm
becomes real so one of the things to
know is that when people are effectively
sitting here and we're not really told
by exactly what means it happens because
they endure all this pain and all this
Agony when they were on Earth and they
believed hell existed once they got here
that belief becomes Paramount it becomes
more tangible and the more they believe
it the more this place be becomes real
to them so as doomsday is making his way
through this place and he's literally
torturing and killing everybody he can
find and while he is being killed he
comes back immune to the way that killed
him the people who see him Revere him as
God now exactly what kind of impact this
has becomes more and more amazing
because what ends up happening is
they're basically brought to a being who
tells them that they get to meet the
devil now something to understand this
guy does not refer to himself as the
devil he does not refer to himself as
the absolute ruler of hell now this is
where things get kind of murky here
right because even if this isn't
necessarily the true hell potentially on
some level it is nine times out of ten
whenever you see the real hell in DC
Comics you see like Lucifer Morningstar
so what this guy does is he says now you
get to meet the devil that can be
interpreted in a couple different ways
and the sense that he's referring to the
actual Devil Himself Lucifer Morningstar
or it could be this actual person right
because where kerazole all kind of
dismisses it the response of Martian
Manhunter is he's not joking Supergirl
he is known as the first of the Fallen
he is Lord of this place the most
powerful being in hell it is he who
brought us here and when she asks are
you reading his mind his response is
he's letting me he knows the knowledge
will scare us he enjoys this very much
and so it's really interesting in terms
of how these things kind of coalesce and
merge with one another and he says alas
that we had time to play where Supergirl
responds in saying this place is an
Abomination a stain on existence his
response is and they believe in it thus
it must exist there could be no light
without Shadow now do you wish to know
why you have been granted audience with
the shadow so the guy refers to himself
in the third person and that's why
things are a little bit murky because if
the entire existence of this place is
that it only exists because Humanity
believes it exists and this guy refers
to himself as the third person then he's
not actually lose user for Morningstar
maybe he is maybe he's not I want to
know what you guys think in the comments
do you think this is actually hell and
do you think it's actually the Lucifer
morning star that we know exists in DC
Comics but the long and short of this is
he says if the Damned believe doomsday
is King he shall be so and he can do
anything if enough of them do believe he
can leave this place and walk among the
living once more it is his psychic
tether to you Martian Manhunter that has
allowed him to find a Gateway back to
your dreary well and the belief of the
Damned is opening it for him so that's
what's so cool because literally we get
another shot of Doomsday who's just
ripping through this entire place right
Souls of the Damned who are being
tormented and whatnot he's like
destroying and killing various demons so
on and so forth and he's becoming more
and more powerful all the while to the
point that his level of power would
actually challenge this guy right
assuming it is the devil it would be
enough to rival him and to take it over
more so than that because belief becomes
reality in this place if they believe
him to be God he would become as
powerful as God which is kind of a
horrifying concept doomsday with the
power of God walking through Earth
challenging various people and intending
to like destroy them and whatnot what
hope does Superman have against an
unkillable guy with the power of God it
would be kind of nuts and so what he
does is he basically directs Martian
Manhunter and Kara zorrell to defeat
this guy or at the very least to
challenge him in such a way to where the
people begin to lose their faith in him
and that's what happens right Martian
Manhunter responds now one of the things
I want you guys to know here and one of
the things I want you guys to understand
even with Supergirl there's always been
this kind of ongoing debate is Supergirl
more powerful than Superman and I would
argue yes she is and a lot of people
infer to the events of like Crisis on
infinite Earth where you had like these
varying versions of Superman who were
all fighting and Supergirl was like the
last one left there's been all kinds of
fan theories as to why that's the case
but that's where that idea of her being
stronger than Superman comes from again
I'm inclined to go with that with the
new 52 and DC rebirth you know DC's kind
of changed things up a bit and so on and
so forth but in Justice League of
America or at least JLA by Grant
Morrison and I want to say it's issue
number 98 I'm not entirely sure the
story was written in a way where
Superman made the Declaration then
Martian Manhunter is the most powerful
being on Earth and even more powerful
than him now it's not just simply
strength that allows that to happen
right it's the fact that he has
telepathy he's got just shape-shifting
abilities his durability is off the
charts right that kind of a thing so the
other powers he has in addition to the
somewhat traditional Superman powers of
like strength and flight and so on and
so forth that's what amplifies them and
so seeing a true knockdown drag out
fight between Supergirl and Martian
Manhunter teaming up against doomsday is
something we've never really he's seen
before now for Supergirl herself yes
she's wildly capable but of her own
accord she couldn't defeat this guy
especially considering the new level of
power that doomsday had so to complement
her abilities the devil had given her a
kind of armor that would allow her to
channel his own power and the power of
Hell itself which she does and she wrets
the sky it's not enough to kill him but
it is enough to at least knock him
unconscious and to basically take him
out leading other people to believe that
he's not really as powerful but it's not
enough right there's still enough people
there who believe that doomsday is this
king of hell that he could take the
place over and so what ends up happening
is Martian Manhunter in himself and Kara
zorrell being crushed by doomsday
basically reaches out to the denizens of
Hell itself and calls on them to
effectively believe that doomsday is not
powerful right he literally says mortal
Souls of hell I am sorry to ask this of
you you who have suffered so already but
I need your help you are spirits of what
was once Humanity you have descendants
allegiances and loved ones among the
living they will perish if doomsday
leaves this place they will suffer as
you do you believe he is powerful enough
to do so and I shall not lie to you
perhaps this makes him so but there is
one thing I ask of you perhaps more
powerful than belief that it's hope he
literally calls on them to basically
Channel his hope and to channel their
energy and to effectively stop believing
that doomsday is as powerful as he is
that there's no conceivable way that
doomsday would be able to escape hell
and that's what's kind of funny it's
because it almost kind of seems to be a
lost cause and in fact that's what the
story says this is the place where there
is no hope in fact if you believe in
like Dante's Inferno and the idea of the
Catholic depiction of Health once you
get in there right above it says abandon
all hope ye who enter here here so
asking for Hope from people who have
long since lost it is a tall order but
then someone steps up and channels their
belief into the fact that doomsday is
not the king of hell and then others
follow and they literally form this is
kind of enormous door that doomsday
simply just can't get past it's the one
thing that keeps them from being able to
escape and so following that with
doomsday defeated his power effectively
waning the devil retakes control of hell
and then Martian Manhunter and Kira
zorel are whisked back to Earth what's
cool about this is that even given the
power of Doomsday and what he's capable
of this guy's desire to come out on top
is Relentless this guy if given enough
time will inevitably escape and in fact
we're told that right like Doomsday
story continues in the pages of Superman
in Action Comics this guy will escape
hell this guy will return to Earth and
he'll challenge Superman and everybody
else once more so with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
thank you all for watching let me know
what you think in the comments and I
will catch you all later
peace